hey everyone it's a 10:00 p.m. right now
but you know it's Tuesday so that means
it's a tidy Tuesday analysis day today I
think we're gonna be actually analyzing
NHL goals so I'm not really a hockey guy
I'm actually from Iowa so we'll see what
we can do here but when we're looking
over the actual data set it comes with
three data sets one where I guess has
the game goals the top 250 and then also
the season goals and we look at the the
days that we see top 250 means I guess
the ranking of the players so the top
250 players so that's pretty cool and
then game goals it actually has goals
for each player for every game and then
for season we actually have each
player's season goals so I'm not really
someone who knows a lot about hockey
however I think we can still do
something kind of interesting and one of
the things that I was thinking about
doing when I was looking at this data
set is we could actually NHL we actually
maybe do some like some linear models
but instead of trying to actually
predict something we're actually gonna
use it to analyze the coefficients so
it's more of an actual marketing problem
it's it's using marketing lot where
people will try to predict like
propensity of someone will buy a product
and analyzing what kind of factors make
them buy the product so in this case
we're gonna actually gonna load in the
data first and we're gonna look at I
think game goals will probably be the
best so let's do game goals and just do
a basic glimpse okay and we're gonna pop
this up to so we see here we get a
player a season some kind of ranking for
that season a date a game number their
age team and all this other times and
stuff and one thing that I'm thinking at
think about is maybe we should predict
how many goals they'll
score right per game and then we'll
actually kind of like make a model and
kind of predict what we're gonna expect
each player to score for each game so
let's let's start doing that let's let's
first collect our data and do some maybe
some data cleaning so game goals and one
thing that I think it's gonna be a kind
of a cool idea is maybe make a model for
each player or maybe each player
grouping so we're gonna select player
season
and we'll do game numbers so I think
that corresponds season their age the
team opposition team
location location will do goals assists
and I think shots okay so now we have
their player the season the game number
their age what team they're playing on
what team they're facing whether it was
a home our way the goals they made the
assist they made and also the shots they
made and I'm actually gonna do some
formatting because we want to predict
goals so that way we have goals right
here and one thing that we should
probably see is who are the top players
or what's what should just count how
many players there are so we can see
that there's in this day set there's
only about forty two players and I think
that makes sense probably because I
think it's doing the top let's here top
250 player top 250 things or career
goals okay so these are the players who
you know during the season had the top
250 goals ever scored during a season
which makes sense there shouldn't be
about 200 players who do that so you
know if you're good you can probably be
good for a while and you're gonna
probably break multiple records that
kind of makes sense okay so we have four
or two players but I'm actually going to
make this
into just so I don't that explicitly say
it all I can all just call it a DF for
fun and maybe we should figure out how
many goals each person has actually made
right so we'll do a a group by player
and then we'll just do a summarize and
then mmm total goal goal goal equals
some goals and we'll do total assists
equals total so sis and then we'll do
you want we'll do total shots equals
some shots okay and let's see here
I'm actually not made this go down a
little bit
um let's first kind of range it by total
goals
who is scoring the most amount on goals
and it's a Wayne Gretzky that's that I
think I've heard that guy right I think
I'm sure people who who know hockey know
more than me but that kind of makes
sense I've heard him of her bottom
before um let's see who's the guy with
the most assists to Wayne Gretzky again
no so that guy is both a all score and a
team player I always like to see it
who's shooting the most oh okay cool you
know I kind of have an interesting idea
let's do a mutate and say like goal to
shot percentage so how many how many
shots does it take for them to make a
goal so shots per will do per goal and
then equals total shots divided by total
goals sweep and then we'll do it and
arranged by shots
yes shots
oh I kind of I kind of don't like how
when you arranged it all might be sorted
from like low as the highest I kind of
wish it was just a default on high
stylist maybe that's just me but I think
it's always I always feel like I'm
always adding des C or just a minus sign
- can I get away with it maybe they
should just say a like a hierarchy
function or something like that what
whatever
okay so Justin Williams he has 10 shots
per goal so he's not very good ooh but
he takes a while to shoot to make his
goals but he makes a lot he does a lot
of shots so actually we're gonna arrange
it by that this is then one time when I
criticize arrange for using descending I
actually need to use it without the
descending this that's a that's a little
ironic um Jerry Curry this guy is a very
efficient shot maker right so he's only
takes some if he shoots five times you
know one of those five times he's
shooting a goal cool and maybe we'll do
a plot why not
AES x equals will say since x is the
explanatory variable we'll say total
shots results in total goals and we're
just gonna do a simple point point okay
and then maybe you might we'll do a well
just a smoothing - let's see what goes
in there yeah so it's kind of a linear
ish pattern yeah and you know that there
is a distinctive positive relationship
where the more shots you make the more
goals you'll make sure you'll probably
make - yeah that makes sense so now we
kind of did an e da not a great a da I'm
not gonna lie but we kind of we did
something where we kind of looked at it
one thing I'm gonna look at actually is
let's do it ggplot actually what you
select assists shots and then goals
right and then we'll do a GG Ally and
we'll do like a GG duo
and the GG Ally is probably one of my
favorite um packages for my classes we
usually have to do it exploratory data
analysis on our on a bunch of numerical
data and GG Ally can basically do most
of the assignment um I remember one
project for data mining we actually just
created this huge faceted faceted graph
where it just showed all these bivariate
relationships and we just kind of like
projected it onto a screen and we just
looked at it for like 20 minutes to
figure out some kind of relationships
and we're actually analyzing like like
website data and trying to predict like
consumer purchasing stuff like that so
that was that was a lot of fun and GG
how I did most of the work for us we
actually just were staring at charts we
don't have to do anything crazy so it's
gonna be running it's kind of being slow
for some reason and probably as there's
a lot of data
I'd say DF has 49,000 yeah that's gonna
be this can be a little slow I'm gonna
have to arrogate it a little bit but
we're gonna let it run and we're gonna
think about how what else we're going to
do so when I'm looking at this data we
should probably I think it's kind of a
stupid idea to make 42 models that seems
you know a little a little too much so I
think one thing that we could do is make
it so it's like a grouping where we'll
say okay we'll just make little bins
where it's like if you're in there like
the top 25 percent our top 10 percentile
will say you're like an elite level
person for like 10 to 20 percent range
of goals made then you'll be kind of
like a semi elite level so I think we're
how we're gonna do this is we're just
gonna let's see here when are you a
group bye-bye and then we'll say later
and then we'll do you take and then
we'll say total goals
it goes some goals and then we'll
actually ungroup it ungroup it and I
think one thing that we could do is just
do a ranking so I'll say uh player rank
and we could have done player right oh
there we go okay so we have assists with
goal assist with assists so we have a
linear relationship and then we have
assists with shots where shots is the
x-axis okay so it's kind of common all
over the place
goals and assists right here okay one
thing that I think it's kind of
interesting is how shots is just all
over the place right you have some what
is it heresy audacity or something where
the variance is changing a little bit
weird okay anyways that's that's our eta
for now we're not gonna go too much into
it we're okay goals and assists pretty
unit almost pretty uniform but we need
one bad thing about this is we don't
really see the heat map of it right we
don't know if there's like 20 points
right here or just one point it's kind
of just all our voice we're actually
gonna you know what I'm gonna change
this I'm gonna do we're gonna make it
better than one a better one so key
equals key value equals value okay and
then I think I'll do ggplot AES x equals
key y equals value
I think giome point I think it's a fasiq
grid right where see your rows equals
what it's like bars key I'm not sure
that's right but we'll see if they'll
work okay
oh well and then actually I had an idea
gather key equals key equals value and
minus goals and then we'll do Gd plot
AES X X equals value y equals goals
color yeah we'll do it
the plus giome point
place a facet wrap key scales equals
free cool this'll this will do it
this is basically what we wanted anyways
and then instead of GM point so this is
the same this is kind of the same thing
we got from the GE GE GG do well or
giome dual will do GM jitter and see
what's going on here
and the jittering - okay so right here
we got some crazed things I'll fly
equals point one so we can kind of have
a like a heatmap going on where if it's
more dense or there's more points around
I'll be darker there we go so this is
this is what we kind of wanted to see
okay so we can kind of analyze this as
almost a heat map where if we're
predicting goals so assists and goals
generally people with our kind of
centering around right here you know
centered around zero to two goals and
zero to two assists we're also our axes
are actually a little bit skewed where
assists are a little under
representative for right here is six and
we're right here is actually five okay
and then with here with shots and goals
we do still seek a kind of a linear
relationship let's do a gym smooth see
if that does anything and maybe we can
kind of just see a basic trend from that
and again it'll probably do like some
kind of Lois or something I'll use a
game
okay so we couldn't do it for here it's
it couldn't figure it out but here we
can see some like almost like you know
the more the shots taper off you know
it's not a linear thing where if you're
making ten shots or if you if you're
shooting shots where it's like only if
you five shot for every five shots you
make you make one goal it's not gonna
translate directly to ten shots where if
you make ten shots then you'll make two
goals it has this kind of like a
logarithmic curve going on which makes
sense you know okay
yeah but kinda I kind of got a little
sidetracked but we're gonna do this
first so we're gonna rank these guys
where we'll do rank equals dents
I think it's dense rank and then we'll
say uh total goals okay so just to make
sure it's not doing anything crazy we'll
do select rank and total goals and then
arrange by rank one does that that's it
make 273 that's that's pretty small
right we'll do uh okay so yeah we gotta
we gotta reverse that so we'll say uh
let's do - it's a quick and dirty way to
do it okay so now that we have our ranks
of all 42 players
I got we have to start thing and how are
we gonna make this rank is smaller so I
think we're we'll just do mm for rank
divided by 10 I think
divided by 10 and there's +1 so that way
I think we'll have yeah there we go we
have like percentiles so if you're
between zero and I think ten you'll be
ranked one right so that means you
scored a lot of goals that's great and
we'll actually kind of highlight that by
selecting select rank and total goals
and then we'll do a unique right so no
so we do have some ties okay
arranged right okay so we do have some
ties I think that's how dense rank works
oh no we don't ties we a that makes
sense because if you're in the top
percentile I mean I shoulda did a I
would say been ranked I don't want to
say been ranked boom okay there we go
this right right here so if you're in
what if you're below 10 you'll be if
you're in the top nine or you'll be in
the bend one and then it'll go to four
cool so that's what that's what we want
it right been ranked in our rank and
actually we'll just we'll change that to
just rank we just wanted to use that to
verify that we're not doing anything
crazy although I would probably
recommend you not to do the ranked call
it rank because I think there are
functions for that and you could have
lead into some weird issues okay so I'm
gonna do rank and then everything so I
just wanted to format that so we can
kind of get a good idea of how we're
gonna start modeling this what are we
looking at so I don't think we actually
needs season that doesn't seem like a
relevant thing we don't we probably need
oh well we could use game number two
game number could be maybe a player's
really good at the mid-season then the
beginning in the season right that'd be
interesting we don't need total goals so
we can remove that we kind of you just
use that to rank it age okay let's see
yeah so we got it we got a mess with age
first we see how it took us 20 and 0 1 8
we don't only know what that means
what's let's kind of look at it let's
look at our data table age age and years
and days so we got to separate that
that's okay
we're gonna start cleaning it anyways
okay so to separate these ages I believe
that's just using a separate function
yes an age and we'll say into equals see
a year and
days sweet year in days okay mutate and
then we want day days to be 365 days so
we'll just do a a decimal for the actual
age so mutate age equals as a integer
year plus as the numeric days divided by
365 that won't do anything right and
then I'll be at the end 18 let's make
sure that that makes sense yeah so we
have that now it will will deselect our
year we don't want year anymore - days
I don't need season anymore okay so we
have we have our goals made with a
player we have the game number the team
opponent location assist shots total
goals well we don't need to load those
anymore okay and then we have age cool I
actually kind of like the game number
idea maybe we could bend that to where
it's like what would we classify as
mid-season later half of the season or
we could just do standardization of it
we do like a min/max normalization or
just a standardized normal trying to
think
hmm yeah I'll worry about that later
I think with if we're using a linear
regression we don't want you to worry
about that but we didn't we do that you
said mutate I think there isn't there
are normalized function standardized
yeah we can just wait is that um game no
equals mean game X minus means so
game oopsie game no - mean / SDV game no
I will say standardized game just select
standardized game num and then game oh
wow there's a lot of game numbers okay I
think that's fine then we'll just we'll
be like that okay so now we want we
don't need game dumb anymore
- game you know and we just have our
goals our player our team our opposite
position our location assists shots rank
age standardized okay what did I what am
I forgetting right now oh yeah I forgot
my my rank where's my rank at oh there
it is this ring he's okay and we also
don't need our player names we're just
gonna make I've did I decide we're just
gonna make a model for for linear
regression models for the top 10% you
know between 10 and 20 30 20 and 30 and
30 and 40 so we don't need a player
anymore okay Oh what oh I got hungry
this and group oh we should actually
recruit this by rank there we go
ungroup' select yeah so I actually
grouped it by rank because we can't we
don't want to do it by player on we want
to aggregate it a little bit more so
we're just gonna we're gonna group it by
rank which makes a little bit more sense
then we're gonna deselect player okay
now I'm just gonna kind of format it so
it it looks nicer so we want to predict
goals we want to also want goals will do
ranked goals and then everything right
so now we have our rank our goals our
game numbers so we don't need our game
number anymore okay so we have a rank
our goals the team that they played on
opposition location assists shots age
standardized game over
you know I think there might be some
type of data leakage going on with the
team we might have to do another EDA a
little bit and just kind of look at what
is our ranking so we're gonna do a group
by rank oh-oh-oh we got to add that on
so I'm gonna just do that first and I'm
gonna do a group by rank we're gonna
count what teams are on I don't want to
make it so okay let's see it okay let's
see okay
and then I'll do a count rank ok so
there's there's a decent sample of like
22 2014 16 17 okay and then actually
I'll do a on group arranged by team
actually would you go now a team rank so
it seems like every every team kind of
has a decent distribution of like good
players like high high tier players you
know all these players are high tiered
just like high tiered players and low
tier II players so we don't we don't
have other word oh this one team has all
the great players so that that way we
know that there there's some kind of
contribution to it so we Russian call us
model data I think we have everything we
have our our rank our goals our team
opposition location assist shots age
sweet let's run the model okay so what
school are our is if you want to even
though we're just writing we're just
running for technically just for models
it is kind of nice to be able to know it
you can run a bunch of like all micro
adjusted models right so we're gonna
start doing that I'm trying to figure
out mmm yeah we're just gonna do that so
we're actually gonna we're gonna use the
broom package which is a great package
for these kind of like simple sad sad
things where ours definitely known to
being a statistics language however it
kind of sucks for statistics it's not
very as user-friendly as the tiger
versus so a guy named I think David
Robinson and ended up the broom package
which really makes on this statistical
tests such as a linear regression ANOVA
and chi squared into a very tidy ask
module so like if you run it out
you can actually plot it very easily
into pipes so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do a basic linear model so
we'll say linear model equals LM and
then we'll do goals boom right let's see
if that runs it should run the boom and
right there we've made four models for
each little ranking of tears right so
now kind of wondering asking like oh how
do we even look at these models so we'll
just do tidy linear linear model and we
got it okay and I'm gonna do something
kind of cool where a s x equals term y
equals estimate color equals rank plus
gym call that's it wrap and we'll do
rank and I'm gonna do something funny
and say scales equals fix because I want
that access to be fixed so we can kind
of compare and contrast these these
linear models oops don't worry do a cord
flip whoa so this is not a pretty chart
at all
one thing I'm going to do is actually
with the linear models we kind of just
want to look at significant values so
we're gonna do a filter p-value less
than or equal to 0.05
instead just our clear it out a little
bit okay
and I can't really see it so I'll do fig
dot height equals 20 fig with equals 20
okay interesting I'm not even gonna do a
quarter flip this is very confusing
that's even more confusing okay we're
not gonna do that we're just gonna look
at it okay so each interesting team so
we can see right here when they play for
I think when we said their team their
scoring less goals right weird we could
see what the opponents it's a little bit
different
hmm let's see I'm trying to think of how
we would do this okay ggplot is x equals
term reorder term estimate y equals
estimate hill equals rank facet wrap
oops
scales we're gonna make it free now
skills there we go that makes a little
bit better so I guess we're gonna have
to do scales eagles free I know I said I
wasn't gonna do it but I I kind of like
anyways so now we have something
interesting for the top tier for the top
tier guys we can see that Schatz plays a
huge factor plays a largest factor and
we see how these teams
actually kind of prohibit the player
from making some goals however for the
second tier people we can see how IDI
the team EDM has definitely helped a lot
opponent Quebec has helped a lot maybe I
think it's Quebec make all that kind of
kinda isn't as good and we can all see
like aged it doesn't really play that
large of a factor yes it does hinder it
a little bit but it's not crazy and then
we can see how most of these possibly
influence these lower tier guys but we
do have a main one main problem with
this is for one thing we actually don't
have these these values are not actually
one hunt not they're not dummied so what
that means is you're gonna face a lot of
like : your culinary issues so what
we're gonna have to do is fix that and I
believe the way to do it is you make it
let's see Ritz dot and then says I think
it's just like plus plus zero right plus
dot and then plus zero is how you do it
yeah and then we can kind of do a linear
model there we go and when you say plus
zero it means we set the intercept
specifically for zero and that's kind of
makes sense for how dubbing variables
work because dumbbells have some kind of
contribution to the intercept where say
if it's male or female
if it's male is the one when it's zero
we'll add that as to intercept so since
we aren't doing it where it's we
basically have a male and a female calm
we'll just try to negate the fact that
we don't have dummy variables with and
said we sure are using one Hungary
Buhl's so Walker you just switch to
y-intercept to zero and that should fix
that up a little bit okay so now we're
actually it's gonna run this again and
see what we're missing so I'm gonna say
and we get yeah seems we get different
results right we get way more
contribution for the
for the first team okay again and then
linear regression 101 also we are doing
something that we shouldn't really be
doing and one thing is we actually do
know or we can make a we make an X we
make an educated guess on it where our
goals and stuff I think there's probably
some type of like interaction effects
and interaction effects is when you just
kind of multiply it so for example I
think most team most players will shoot
more on certain opponents right so we're
gonna have to add that type of effect so
we're gonna do that do that and we'll
say opponents times shots let's see if
that'll work right and now we have more
of something and we're actually we're
just gonna filter the p-values and say
less than or equal to 0.05
oops p-value all right and right here we
could see that interaction effect is is
significant and we're actually gonna
plot this out too so I'm gonna I'm gonna
copy and paste this again and we're
gonna learn a little bit more about oops
confounding variables where in marketing
this is a huge problem where confounding
variables are basically overestimating a
coefficient for a variable if we just
use one variable to predict something it
might get a nice r-squared value but in
reality there are other values that are
actually affecting it there might be
correlate or some type of thing like
that
so instead we were actually overstating
how much something contributed so for
example let's look at this or we might
have been understanding right so once we
add these types of things we can see how
oh well we got ranked in there for some
reason uh let's hear how would I do that
so we can see that these shots now added
more where as a quue
is much lower now alright it's much
lower okay oh wow how could I - Frankie
there we go oh no no actually I want to
look it up how to remove a column in a
linear model now what I had okay
there we go okay so I guess you just put
that in there so again I I was actually
kind of messing up the thing so I'm just
an ad that just uh make sure when I made
a data leakage but I shouldn't change
much okay so if you notice something we
came from right here having one two
three four five all the way down to
three three actually statistically
significant variables and that's pretty
good because our interaction effects
actually added something to it so we can
now see a better picture because we
added okay we add some interaction where
we know or we believe that given the
person or given these these these tears
of people they might shoot more on like
weaker teams okay so we can see that oh
yeah shots definitely plays a huge thing
age kind of hurts a little bit and
assists kind of hurt a little bit
because if someone's making more assists
they might be not shooting as much for
their own self-interest well we can see
here how there's still a lot of terms
right here
and even though um some terms increased
and some terms decrease we have a better
picture of it we can see how the
opponent opposition with the interaction
effective shots plays a huge role in the
third tier so I like equals twenty
equals so let's let's expand this pot a
little bit
oh yeah and we can see right here what's
what's interesting about this one is it
kind of seems like it's depend on the
team maybe there's like a huge like
super team for the EDM not sure but we
can see right team EDM and tea medium
are huge for two and fours
what one thing that I think will be also
interesting to model all right is a
head-to-head matchups maybe that'll fix
a lot of it too so we'll do op times uh
I think it's team right team yeah a team
so let's model that and see what that
looks like okay since we're adding a ton
of interaction effects it's gonna take a
little bit
okay so 34 seconds let's just kind of
look at these this pot a little bit more
yeah it's it's it's kind of interesting
we can see our shots team tpo I think
with the most interesting thing is shots
matter when these guys are shooting
they're scoring points whoa okay and now
we can see these head to heads are huge
right
EDM x NY EDM x NY are these guys matter
and maybe maybe we might just remove
teams all like for the entire thing
right maybe we want to create an
actually simpler model and we're gonna
we're just going to do that too and this
one will be our final model for today so
I'm gonna do my opponent my esteem just
just the bare minimum stuff and then
we'll do a group by rank do what do ma
yeah we'll do a linear model Eagles LM
goal goals goals Bob and then say minus
rank all right and then we'll say okay
they closed dot okay and will tidy those
linear linear
model and boom we still have that one
thing that is kind of interesting we can
actually do augment so we're gonna do
that I'm gonna say oops we're gonna
weird and create a final thing where
we're just gonna add some Rolla generic
effects or we're not gonna add a rank
we're gonna say I bet shots x location
play something
I bet assists x shots play some type of
role
plus assists x shots and also will say
no rank Oh where I have that rank and
we'll say no interest except his home
away probably not getting no I mean okay
and then we did an augment right so that
that just applies this model to all the
data sets and then we can kind of just
plot it out we're ASX equals dot fitted
y equals goals color equals rank and
we'll do geom point let's see what that
looks like okay
help rankings mutate Frank goes ass that
factor rank your frog again film okay
and then actually do idea
Gator alpha equals point three sweet so
the model it's not the best model right
but we can't analyze a lot from this
right we can't analyze the p-values very
quickly and extract some sort of effect
so if we do yes actually we'll term
wykel's
right we can't analyze something home in
a way don't really matter all right
home in a way if they're at home or way
they they still go so we can we can fly
filter out
however shots age always matter too and
that's kind of what we expect and one
thing that we could look at is we know
yeah actually but one thing that we can
take away is like okay if someone make
wants to make a lot of goals they
shouldn't should go for this sister
should go for broke and shoot a lot
they might not win the game but they're
gonna make a lot of goals right and
that's basically how you should do it
that's how and that's basic how you can
kind of analyze models really fast one
thing that I was I was thing about is we
can actually kind of go over the I think
the glance function because I was trying
to figure out what it was called again
well I think this will yeah right here
and this will kind of give you just
model summary statistics of it right
where we can kind of see how you know it
doesn't really describe it doesn't
really
playing a lot of the variants you know
maybe maybe it's not the best but if we
look at our residuals you know we can we
can see that our fourth model is
probably best for that model and we can
apply it to our other our other ones too
so if we don't adjust to look at these
guys so let's look at what's compared to
our very complex model so that's let's
do that one actually we'll do yeah we
need that one and we'll add all of this
all this weird stuff right all these
interaction effects too and we'll see
which one's better right so we added a
lot of crazy interaction effects and
then we're gonna compare it to this a
simple model that's just comparing you
know it shots times location we think
they'll shoot a little bit more on the
location if they're a home or away and I
want to say you know assistant shots are
probably have some kind of relationship
with each other so we'll just create
that kind of interaction - it's a very
simple model but let's compare it to a
this really crazy little interaction
effect model that you probably actually
do need more domain knowledge to
actually fit know but we'll kind of
compare it and what we are looking for
right now is we would hope that this
complex model would probably explain
more the variance and it would have like
lower bi SI scores and stuff like that
but again we're not gonna you know we're
not gonna cry if it if it's not better
or not okay
well it's taking a while just a generic
linear model but you know linear models
take a long time - they're not there's
still fast but when you add a bunch of
other computations it's gonna be a
little bit slower and also just to just
explain though though I guess the
modeling thing it's saying like this
little Tillet thing is like Y - X so Y -
everything and the little periods like
saying like oh we're gonna compare goals
to all the other variables that are in
the data set but we're also adding you
know opponents time shots opponents and
team stuff like that oh that's why I
don't so it has like opponents time
shots and then opponent - team
interaction - ring because we don't want
to do that and then we have shots x
location assistant assists time shots a
lot of weird things like that actually I
need it I don't stop at this supposed to
be a cool
stop oh no
so yeah it's just doing opponents first
time shots interaction fact opponent in
team interactions not including rank to
avoid any data leakage shots times to
the location whether it's home or away
and then also assists time shots
okay we're looking at and as we would
have expected our r-squared values are a
little bit higher right we get we got
three percent performance for about
about a three to four percent of
performance our bi C scores are much
higher - that's pretty cool and then
we'll get our visit our residuals are a
little bit smaller so this model is a
little bit better than our original
model okay so let's see here
so I hope you learned a little bit more
about linear regression and supposed
specifically about interaction effects
and confounding variables that's it for
this Tiger Tuesday so I'll see you
hopefully next week